Hmm.
No, this is
the wrong remote.
What must I do?
What do you want
from me?
Look, lady, this is
the wrong remote,
and this is the right remote.
Okay, you gotta get
the right remote.
I had to find out I may
or may not have herpes
to get this remote!
Can I speak to
your manager, please?
Oh, I am the manager.
I also do billing,
installation programming,
and I compose
the "on hold" music.
You composed this music?
Oh, no, no, this is
the "waiting room" music.
I compose that too.
I'm actually the only
person who works here.
Yikes.
Okay, what are
my options?
You can either mail in
a check for $1,000,
or come in person
and pay $5.
You're only the fifth person
ever to come in.
Oh...
Here.
I can pay
in quarters, right?
Oh, actually, no.
Our system's down
and we only take nickels.
Sorry.
Oh, and you know what?
I hate your music.